what is orange grove Laura Grove is an
incubator for young entrepreneurs
there's about 60 young people from
Greece but also a couple of them from
Holland that learn how to set up a
business here but but what is so
extraordinary is that this is an
initiative of the Dutch embassy
embassies don't usually get involved in
economic stimulation where did you get
the idea from well we are doing this as
the embassy but together with a number
of dutch in Greek companies and with a
number of universities and why are we
doing this because we think that one of
the big challenges for Greece is to do
something about the brain drain and the
youth unemployment that might be the
cause of a lost generation in Greece if
you don't do anything about it and we
thought well let's try to do something
using the fact that we have a very
flourishing interesting startup
community in Amsterdam nowadays and when
you first came here to the two to Athens
I mean you know what was the reaction
when you came up with the orange grove
idea because a lot of people in I
imagined Greece would look towards the
Netherlands and say but the Netherlands
this is the people who are putting the
kibosh on us with the austerity well
you're too there there are pretty strong
negative judgments nowaday in Europe
some countries have very strong opinions
about other countries but it was also a
reason to do this we want to show that
it pays off to collaborate we want to
show that we want to be positively
engaged in a country like Greece and
that's that's that work pretty well we
got very positive reactions people like
it they say you're not only criticizing
you're also doing positive things you're
trying to help the younger generation
what's of the companies are coming here
where were sort of startups do we see
here all kinds of startups about half of
them are I CT apt builders and so on but
there's also people that work in tourism
and agriculture and for instantly
creative sector
you